[Music]
all right
you know i like some wii we know
it's got me super high wait let's start
at the beginning okay
all right i was in the second one it's
such a great start though josh
ready you know i like some weed
it's got me super high
let's go get some munchies
[Music]
i think i can drive
let's go to taco bell
get a gordita supreme
[Music]
we'll drive through mcdonald's
get a fries and some drinks
i need some sweets
candy or baked goods
too many choices i have
[Music]
and i know what i want
ready where's that party going we
that one we
go to seven eleven
i'll get some skittles
i love skin
[Applause]
[Music]
skin
where'd i put my keys
[Music]
i had them right here
you know where my phone is
i don't know where my phone is
[Music]
let's stay right here
i can't drive anyway
let's just call postmates
do you know where my shoes are
do you know where my shoes
[Music]
[Applause]
are
ah i [__] hate you i came out here
and sang my heart out you [__]
[Music]
he's like this muzzle of [__] on my
[__] shoe